I wrote a review okay before we get into
it
I wrote a review because I'm going to
work on being a Critic okay I wrote a
review for artifice girl okay I want you
to laid on us I wrote this last night
exiting the theater shouldn't just be a
way to get back to your car and go home
it can be
[Laughter]
wrong
[Music]
hello
terrible they're terrible no sir I love
sex and candy yeah
yeah I know it no I said that first
mother you didn't say in that part I
know but I said the name of the song I
know but I so he can't be like yeah you
got it I got the melody no but I know it
I like sex and candy yeah asthma sex son
can they yeah
who's that Lounge in in MA basic the
lyrics I don't Who's That cast in okay
devious stars in my direction Mama this
is
a dream why do you know all the lyrics
I'm just jamming right why do you know
all the lyrics
Charlie is a dream wow yeah all right I
mean ate something Ding and likes it so
wait hold on why
is that a why do you know all that
because it was a huge song it's killing
me it's thus something what is it it's
the Terribles
Mercy playground rigonauts
frigginots Jason and the frigginots you
know what I'm saying dude it why is it
so it's about you look you look super
blind is it so it's
it's uh from uh New York it's from New
York a song is not from anywhere Marcy
playground is a band Marcy is in New
York so I'm saying maybe it's in
playground in New York all right so
there we go I'm a very cultural very
geographical okay so wait hanging around
downtown by myself and I've had too much
caffeine
thinking about myself
all right but uh I get it now
um black Disco
[Music]
uh
uh that would have turned up Podcast off
honestly if I was listening well guess
what yeah you're not you're not our demo
you're
wearing the most regular orange
button-down I've ever seen in my life
there's absolutely nothing special about
it it's the most regular orange
button-down shirt I've ever seen in my
life what are you gonna do about it
nothing exactly just say that exactly it
is so regular it would be in [__] Old
Navy in 2003 or as Union Bay it's
Wrangler
oh okay yeah that's angular angular
Wrangler uh the way that it makes that
is I don't know Wrangler makes those
colors honestly well they used to these
colors they don't really procure
the good things procure I procure the
best things on offer that the world has
Trump okay and it's like nothing you've
ever seen and I have this same shirt I
have the same shirt it's like nothing
anyone's ever seen just in magenta as
well it's in Orange as well just like
that one it's yeah so it is red as well
so it says something I've seen yeah but
they're all like nothing and you have
all of them I have all of the ones I
said yes and I so they're all like each
other so I've seen that that's those are
like ones I've seen that one no
I've only worn one of them ever on this
show and I'm doing it right now let's
talk about this dude how crazy is it
that Lifeline luxury is out and you can
go catch it right now on patreon
patreon.com Lifeline luxury and let me
tell you something about it it's been
going gangbusters I'll tell you
something about extra episodes of
Lifeline out on the patreon and people
are just eating them up dude you know
what I'll tell you what about Lifeline
luxury okay what dad has been bugging us
oh I know dude for weeks now has he been
able to see it just I got the whole
story okay he's been bugging us let's
set it up by saying our parents watch
every single episode of Lifeline yes
which is cute yeah they look forward to
it and obviously because you know every
Sunday night they like watching it yeah
their favorite people are in it yeah and
uh so my dad because it's not it's
through patreon and not through regular
YouTube yeah uh my dad well obvi my mom
even more because my mom didn't even
know to ask me so at least my dad knows
it should be possible to watch it on the
TV which it is he he just didn't know
how and Chris our producer told him
and that wasn't enough
so he when I came over yesterday he
asked me to do it and I said what about
what Chris Chris told you how to do it
he said yeah I don't know I couldn't
figure it out I said okay then I finally
figured it out and
he seemed to barely care once I did you
know what I'm saying oh wow
so wow that's so shitty yeah it took me
like a long time until I Chris was like
okay no this is how you do it then I was
because I can't do that kind of shitty
yeah yeah you're not good at it yeah
um we'll watch it but I knew you're
gonna do that you're predictable oh wow
um I'm not is what's Wild you're gonna
do that no you didn't you don't know
anything
you don't know anything
so anyways nice to meet you you don't
know anything
so that so then I do to introduce
yourself
then I was like I set it up I set it up
Dad and he was like yeah yeah great and
I was like what
where's the reward in this you know what
I mean so
all right so all right well maybe he'll
thank you now maybe eventually maybe if
he sees it and likes it he'll be like
hey thanks Matt you hooked me up yeah
but he didn't really react that way you
know what I hate
when we would be living at home I mean
many years ago and you could have just
said when we were kids but and
um and you would hear mom be like
oh [__] Chris oh oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
I know what you're talking about god
dude about the computer she did she made
something go away oh she's like I made
it go away what did I do yeah and then
you'd come in fix it this is how it
would always go you'd come in fix it oh
you'd be like oh you just kind of
minimized it here it's right there
always was that all right yeah just hit
the [__] hit the [__] green thing
here yeah and then she'd go okay and
then you you'd walk out down the hall
yep and then dude 80 of the time should
go like this oh [__] wait Chris yes yes
oh never mind oh wow yeah oh [__] Chris
wait oh all right never mind also here's
the thing that bothered me the most yeah
and it's not actually just her this is
the the thing that bothers me the most
is that when you do something like that
for somebody and you say so just so you
know so next time this happens right
right and they're like I'm not gonna
know I'm not gonna know and it's like oh
oh so my time is nothing to you yeah
yeah but your time 15 more seconds just
to learn this for the rest of your life
is too much okay yeah guess what's gonna
happen but it's gonna whatever's gonna
happen with the lifeline luxury which
you can get on patreon.com luxury it's
going to log out or whatever and that's
TV and he's gonna be like yeah I need
you to do it again yep so you know
that's gonna happen I mean I'm looking
forward to that maybe he'll actually
thank me next time yeah
uh I will be in Colorado I will be in
Pueblo Colorado I'll be in Colorado
Springs chrisley.com for tickets uh
interesting that he would be changing
yeah right when it said there was
interesting so I know I know that's nice
Las Vegas I'll be in Las Vegas
um Knoxville Tennessee Little Rock for
some reason in Nashville so chrisley.com
get tickets there and that's great it's
uh one thing that is interesting about
what I talked about about Dad yeah is
that it's fought today this episode's
Father's Day oh yeah that's right it is
it is Father's day so another Father's
day uh I told the story about my dad not
thanking me enough uh there you go yeah
it's Father's Day for me dude I I it's
my first Father's Day having two kids
oh yeah yep how's that so far I don't
know because it's we're recording it
before not even the day yet all right
okay as we're talking I just got back
from Tucson
and I'm just going to go ahead and say
it that show was awesome yeah even I
have no idea oh well it's not there
you're right yeah okay cool that's cool
but it was great a lot of people there
having a good time at the Linda Ronstadt
music hall or whatever thank you named
after yeah I believe so imagine you're
Linda Ronson the one you get named after
was the one in [__] Tucson maybe
maybe she's from there or something who
knows I would take it you know that's
yeah yeah that's a major city major
American city
um
Lifeline luxury though huh yeah
definitely so you can you got to sign up
if you don't sign up it is you ain't she
nice and also you can uh it's just us
bantering no no video submissions or
anything like that but if you do have a
video submission go to uh
watchlifeland.com or the hotline we have
there and uh if you wanna on session
with Matt go to mattelia.com I had some
bro good ones yesterday oh yeah real
good day sessions am I good I mean real
freaky stuff you know people coming at
me with some real freaky stuff okay and
then if you want the merch which is
absolutely incredible lifelinemerch.com
there we go
um I will say this
I
could not sleep last night and I'm
pissed about it you dude all right so
here's what happened I got home I was at
the Laugh Factory I got home
uh
uh I was with a buddy I was like let's
go to my house and order some food he
goes like this nah so I'm like all right
I go home
I want to order spaghetti and meatballs
I didn't though because the place was
closed okay but it's all good you know I
keep it lean but I didn't feel like
keeping it yeah it doesn't sound like
you but um didn't yeah yeah exactly
right because I've been working out like
crazy bro okay keep going don't get
sidetracked I know but I did a big
shoulder day yesterday don't care okay
no one no one watching I did military
presses and then also just with the
dumbbells after that no one's ever cared
and then I did battle ropes at the end
but that was after a bunch of stuff no
one could feasibly care about it's not
even possible that in the future someone
might all right so
um after that I go you know what I
earned it so [__] it so I went to go get
two I I ordered two burgers to the house
because one Burger is a snack I don't
just eat one I really don't like that
thing that you say I just really detest
it can you tell me why yeah because it's
not even remotely true
you know what I mean what do you and
when you're not remotely true and people
say them with complete conviction it
makes me mad what do you mean it's not
birds are big fat slob food that you
don't usually even finish then why do I
eat too
I think because you're a big fat slob
dude and doing it at like midnight dude
let me tell you right now
if you're if you're eating one burger
and you can't finish it and you're a
dude
you're a [__]
you're a [__] even if you leave one
bite just like first of all that's just
like plain schoolyard bully yep [__] and
I said it and it's wrong it's not wrong
dude come on bro it's a little bit it's
just you care what are you everyone's
Mom I'm not finished on your plate
finish what's on your plate but like
you're not even really hungry just wait
a little bit till you can eat a whole
Burger because it's just a snack dude
after you eat a burger I go like this
what do you want to eat you're fat
you're fat burger in your heart in your
soul you're fat so I ate I got two
because I know my [__] I didn't get
fries I got two burgers okay okay to
leave room for the second Burger I
didn't want fries oh okay yeah so then I
sat and I watched a movie
and uh what was it oh my God could you
be more boring could you possibly be
more boring right now
I mean it's like you're trying to set
some records what was the movie I
watched last night oh I don't know our
artifice girl that's such a bad Title by
the way what what yeah it's a bad title
but the movie was really good what is it
it wasn't South by Southwest or
something like that it takes place in
like three different rooms and it's
about AI oh I like the sound whim
shatter I do that now so uh something
sounds good
so uh I ate the two burgers then I
looked and see what kind of sweets we
got ate the sweets and uh then try went
to bed at about 12 30. I wrote a review
for uh I think I know why
you didn't get to sleep okay because you
had two burgers and a bunch of sweets at
12 30. all right so you don't think I
can do that now no you're 48 3 43 don't
say that but the air is on everyone's
fired but um feels good though it does
yeah so I did that and I couldn't sleep
and do you and my question is I didn't
sleep till four I couldn't I was tossing
and turned I tried everything I took a
little bit of Nyquil didn't work NyQuil
goes like this no dude NyQuil I have the
you know this I have the opposite
reaction to NyQuil then is supposed than
you're supposed to have what yeah it
keeps me way wired and awake whoa yeah
it sucks anyway uh I couldn't get to
sleep till four I legit was moving
around and Kristen was like why don't
you just go in the other bed you're kind
of keeping me up and I was like yeah
okay I thought you're sleeping so I went
and I and I finally went to sleep and
that's why I was a little bit late here
I'm really tired but what about what
about the other days that you're late
every day I'm not you're late a lot I'm
late sometimes you're late the thing
about me is I'm like five to ten minutes
late almost all the time yeah you'll be
like 80 minutes late dude I was three
minutes late today I wrote a review
General okay before we get into it
I wrote a review because I'm going to
work on being a Critic okay I wrote a
review for artifice girl okay I want you
to lay it on us I wrote this last night
exiting the theater shouldn't just be a
way to get back to your car and go home
it can
[Laughter]
dude exiting the theater shouldn't just
be a way to get back to your car and go
home it can be much much more and yes we
long for the days where movies leave you
with that wow feeling well the new piece
by Franklin rich is that plus more it
takes Tire tropes and revamps them into
beautifully spun lore this modern
classic rips apart all conventional
filmmaking and throws it out the window
while you're sitting there thinking yeah
this is what I've missed in the movie
since the 70s see artifice girl in the
theater and when you leave that's when a
whole other experience begins
you aren't just walking to your car
you're thinking about the film and how
it exposed Humanity to its very core the
truth is this piece is a gorgeous
thinker dude that is the part that makes
me most mad
that part makes me so mad it was kind of
humorous
until I got to the end
yeah at the very end he didn't write out
five stars he had five star emojis oh
god dude
at 2 30 in the morning he's a great
thinker you know gorgeous a gorgeous
thinker wow
I'm like it's a person
[Laughter]
review or whatever you want to call it
is like the thing you can see a lot of
critics it's a lot of things namely
awful terrible whatever but the thing
that it is the most is that each
sentence it's like missing three
sentences in between yeah yeah you know
what I'm saying I do like you're making
so many leaps that you didn't earn I do
yeah but but anyone could be a movie
critic I could do that now in a massacre
a following right now anybody is a movie
critic and that's improper language but
what I mean is yeah if you read movie
reviews now literally all it is is [__]
like that where it's like right I guy
you have no idea about it I liked it or
I guy you have no idea about didn't like
it yeah that's not criticism that is
your shitty armchair opinion that you're
writing about on some blog that no one
[__] reads submitter yes so anyway we
got tanked you know uh you didn't so uh
that's what that was what I what I wrote
about that at 2 30 in the morning when I
couldn't sleep you don't need to wrap it
up I texted it the things it's over you
know what I mean all right so in short
that is what I wrote but that so
Lifeline luxury is where it's at dude
but right now we're gonna get into
um some uh video submissions worst
Segway guy ever I mean everything I do
is bad you know you're saying
whatever whatever I mean you don't need
to do that made it worse
and I'm from the DMV I want to get
straight to the point because it's very
interesting to me and I'd love your
intake so my dear friend who is Muslim
was talking to and is kind of still
talking to this guy who's Christian if
you were none the wiser you would have
no idea that in the Muslim culture it's
very frowned upon to be with date or
marry anybody outside of college yeah
well I mean people can get disowned for
it that's just their culture and how
they do things
so they had a great time together their
talking stage
um had a lot of great experiences and
made each other really happy but
somewhere down the line he made the
decision to kind of end it because he
felt they were both getting too involved
and invested into something that wasn't
going to end up long term purely due to
religion yeah so I'd love to hear your
take did they say [__] it or should they
respect it I should have been like that
too when I was younger I'm sorry I'm
Muslim here's the deal I can I'm Muslim
with my feelings about that guy thanks
for the Eaton ready yeah
[Music]
yeah
you suck yeah you're so
you're some girl that you really really
like because some books some guy wrote
1400 years ago yeah that sucks that's
the stupid reason but maybe he's not
even Muslim maybe he just says he's
Muslim because he likes I'm trusting her
thanks for the email she knows the guy
and knows the girl involved he's
actually muslim okay thanks for the
email oh babe I would but I'm Muslim but
they don't think they had sex dude if
they're both religious people you don't
have premarital sex thanks for the
talking I'm Muslim
okay so the point is just to thank them
and get out because you're Muslim oh
dude I can't man I'm sorry dude some guy
wrote a book 14 000 years ago I'm mostly
000 years ago
[Laughter]
oh dumb
that is the most set up on a tea thing
for me it's so so so simple and
straightforward it's really hard to find
someone that not only that you love but
that loves you back you can't add things
to get in the way you can't be like my
book that was written 1400 years ago
says I can't marry you in your book that
was written 2 000 years ago says you
can't so like well maybe we shouldn't
like dude the world sucks I know it's
2023. it's obvious nothing matters all
you need to do is go online and see just
be with the person that you like the
most and that likes you the most because
that feels good and that is literally
all we got
so your friends how long ago the guy's
an idiot that was the guy that wrote the
Muslim book
the Quran was written about 1400 years
ago history a little more
who really wrote their names yeah
I can't believe that that's what I said
to Syrian I got I got it right did that
really work yeah oh wow
crazy because I'm smart I know it's the
career wow okay well good uh yeah dude
that's uh yeah that's oh that's so
stupid that guy you know I don't know
everyone honestly religions do it it has
nothing to do with Islam specifically
yeah it's true of Christianity some some
sex of Judaism like I mean any religion
Mormonism
Mormonism is Christianity
yeah yeah okay but uh yeah dude it's
it's it's idiotic top to bottom doesn't
matter what religion it is that it says
that any religion that is the reason for
you to not marry someone you would
otherwise want to marry or just be with
for a long time
that is bad full stop the end there's no
merit to it it is stupid it's like
believing in Santa Claus with a tooth
fairy uh sorry I'm Muslim thanks for the
talking though yeah
what even really make sense though
because what if that's what he said dude
thanks for the talking I'm Muslim
she would have I know what she would
have said what what because I don't I
don't understand what you mean but
anything you said I don't even know your
[__] we didn't do that oh what do you
think she'd say what wait say that again
we didn't even I don't know your [__]
because we didn't even do that anymore
she would be like okay bye no and thank
you for really that is what he said so
she should thank him that's not at all
what he said it's not even close to what
he's but basically he did say that
because he's saying I can't be with you
because I'm Muslim and I'm saying Muslim
because that's what I want to say not
Muslim it's fine okay both work uh but
you're kind of a [__] if you're a white
guy and you're like Muslim but you were
doing it the whole time because I was
making a joke as a comedy podcast oh if
I was giving away people say though I
know but I go Muslim it's like when
people say Jesus no one does that well
in some circles they do it's like when
people say jojoism oh yeah or
um Pakistan
Brian Cowan does that oh you know what I
mean I just want to [__] rip his
Adam's Apple I wasn't getting mad until
you mentioned yeah his name and then I
mentioned his face and then I got mad
there you go so anyway yeah that sucks
man Love Is Love dude and you got to
just be in love and love it and not not
let religion or anybody who wrote any
book 1400 years ago or 14 days ago or 14
000 days or even if it's the client by
John Grisham don't
listen to people who wrote books wow and
love who you want to love you're
extrapolating too much but yeah I love
who you want I'm an extrapolator
sounds like a movie that would come out
with like Denzel Washington no straight
to DVD yeah yeah it's like uh Cole
Hauser and Bruce Willis oh wow dude and
um and uh Devin Sawa okay cool
[__] what's up guys Stefan here from
Serbia tonight I'm huge fan nice
watching your show for a long time
watching uh Chris congratulations
podcast for a bit time in few years yeah
even before uh the Corvette even before
it didn't existed this happened after
that so yeah I got a quick question for
you uh recently my mother passed and it
was uh
you know tough time for me lately and
one good thing that happened to me in
this period
let's say a relationship that I did not
expect at all with the next that I was
with uh let's say half of my life ago or
when we were kids wow really really
young teenagers he looks young and you
know I'm catching some feelings very
fast yeah like maybe we were together
for a month now I mean we are still
together and I'm really feeling a lot I
mean I would say I'm falling in love but
I yeah I lost my mother
in that period like two weeks ago and my
question is for you guys
is it too good to be true you know when
you lose somebody and you meet somebody
I mean not in that order but anyways
when it's almost at the same time is it
possible to be you know like um
to really feel the feelings that you
need to feel or is it all because I you
know lost my mother and now I want to
love somebody else maybe somebody new
okay
Trent you know I really do love this
person this girl and um yeah do you have
some similar experience maybe in your
life when you lost somebody and you also
gained somebody new in your life it can
be a friend maybe love anything yeah so
yeah so is it too good to be true you
know to meet somebody really okay good
for you in the period of your life when
it's all bad yeah thank you guys well
you know The Reincarnation is a real
thing it could be his mom it's not a
real thing but that also is [__] up he
doesn't want to hear that he doesn't
want to be like oh oh the woman actually
fell in love with was was my mom lovely
the joke is that she was alive when the
mom was alive anyway can't be ah you
know they [__] it all up okay well I
think you [__] it up by making it but
no dude I just I do I just love how
matter of fact it was just like you know
I would say I am you know not falling in
love so yeah like that's just Serbian he
was very yeah so Eamon loves her what to
do now you know like that's how you do
it I think that I I I get the question
he's asking it's kind of it's a little
bit complicated because you need comfort
basically saying am I falling in love am
I being vulnerable to feeling like I'm
falling in love just because I'm so
in so much pain my mother passing away
and my life is in such flux right I
would say actually it doesn't matter
because your experience of
of your experience is that you're
falling in love and you can't be like
well no I think I'm just doing it
because this this and this it doesn't
matter if you're feeling the feeling
then you're that it's legitimate and
it's what's actually going on and you
should not you should not lessen its
significance in your mind or certainly
shouldn't like put the brakes on it just
because you're worried that it's some
kind of like replacement for these
feelings also that's how life goes it's
just that's such a massive scale version
of it usually you know when our hearts
are more open and seeking maybe some
kind of companionship or love we're more
likely to to find it because our hearts
are more open and because we're more on
the lookout for it like you're you
didn't mean to have your mother die and
then have this big hole in your life but
it happened and now you do and you are a
person with that hole and who cares if
the reason is that or whatever something
else yeah it's just it all comes down to
a few things do you have fun with her
and is the E on good because all else it
doesn't matter dude it really doesn't
matter I mean you could make a case that
he needs to heal first
being good doesn't matter you could make
a case matters well EU matters but it's
like
other stuff matters I think same the
same amount as you yeah but not being
happy like being happy is the above
being happy is above all but that's why
I said it first but it comes down to a
few things does she are you happy
hanging out with her is it fun and how's
the you know because if they eat but I
don't think that's third or second I
think it's like what I think is that
there's the top it's like General
happiness whatever that means to whoever
yeah and then it's like a few things in
the next category so just to say the two
implies that is the EU good is is as
important as this General happiness I
don't know man I think the Eaton is high
on that list I used to not think so but
you know you're not allowing for the
distinction and Nuance that I'm adding
to the conversation so you think it's
about happiness what else is the eat no
good that's what I'm saying but no but
you're stopping after is the evening
yeah right it's only about the happiness
yeah right all right so then what uh uh
I mean that's it okay so I'm just
kidding
um yeah I don't know but that's not the
point keep going I know no no I get it I
I think it comes down to a few things
and you know what Matt says is true
here's the deal you gotta hopefully
you're not in like this sort of fever
dream kind of weird area in your life
where oh my God my mom died I'm not who
I normally am yeah right and I fell in
love at this moment because I do think
that there is something to be said about
feeling your feelings and also uh
figuring out how to cope with this
before you involve someone else but also
it happened the way it happened yeah and
as long as you're happy with her and
then it was nice I feel like it's good
truly also he didn't seem like a man in
a tail spin yeah I mean who knows but
no hole in his head at the moment he
seems pretty he could have got it yeah
he could have just put it together for
the video who knows he just stop
sticking videos
I mean bro you never know yeah
people because dude like even like as
much footage as they're out of me on the
internet like people come up to me
sometimes and or I get messages or
somebody sent a message to my wife the
other day and it was like uh man I
didn't realize that Chris was like such
a nice guy and he was so soft spoken and
like appreciative and like and it's like
did they just think that I'm gonna be
like
ah you're a piece of [__] you know
probably just because that's how I am on
the [__] podcast my point is people
think that people don't you can't tell
who someone is just by that much footage
so maybe this guy could be in a real
real real Targaryen but got it together
for a little bit I think it's kind of
like a
forgive me for generalizing but I think
serbians just be based on life
circumstances yeah certainly previous
generations yeah they're probably like
less
bulldozed by things in life 100 people
in America are you know totally uh so I
think there tend to be more even keeled
and uh you know I am falling in love I
would say I am in love um
yeah my mother died and I am falling in
love and my mother died fallen in love
it was hard to have mother die and then
I fell in love it's beautiful anyway
um yeah just so chilly I will have the
chicken talking to the waitress all
right so chill about the two most
extreme things anyway I will have
Falafel or whatever they eat over there
wow so racist I have no idea okay
I don't have any advices needed I just
wanted to clear up uh an argument
between Chris and Matt oh
um
for the sneeze
so I want to start by saying never lie I
agree with Matt on that don't lie
there's no purpose for it but the I'm
the guy that called in uh
he was sharing a bed with a friend oh
right yeah of course yeah
say it though say it yeah what just for
for people that see this episode but not
that episode it was it was this guy had
just started dating a girl uh that he
was really into but just prior to that
he had made plans to go on this big
European trip with a really good friend
of his who happened to be female and
happened to be a girl he was he had just
met has like these sort of issues from
the past that were bubbling up about
this trip he was taking and instead of
you know he felt the pressure of this
new situation he was in and instead of
telling her the truth which was that
they were going to be sharing a room
together on their travels because money
and less rooms the better yeah if you
have friends it's easier to stack them
up anyway
um he lied to her and said they were
staying in separate rooms they were on
the phone one night she's still in the
states he's in Europe he's in bed with
his friends his girlfriend doesn't know
that his friend sneezes like an [__]
ruins everything and then these
girlfriend is like who was that and the
guy says it was me big mistake yeah and
now this woman has uh I'm angry with
that woman for sneezing but yeah my
point was like you shouldn't have lied
in the first place yeah you shouldn't
but now that you but in the meantime
since we did don't sneeze go ahead
I'm leaning more towards the fact that
this woman sneezed on purpose yeah to
sabotage that phone call and that
relationship totally be true because she
has feelings for him uh we Chris was
right you could have you know she could
have gone in the bathroom she could have
left the room she could have covered her
face so in my perspective
to that friendship then he thinks and I
think she purposely
sneezed God loud enough for this other
girl to hear
um I don't know you decide but yeah
let me tell you what I'm happy about I'm
happy she made this this video and said
what she said I'm happy Chris picked it
well yeah me too because it seems like
good in a way that you have to be smart
to be able to recognize that it's good
and he's not that smart yeah but he
figured it out you figured it out I'm
going to I'm going to say I bet he'd
even watch a [__] video and just
click no how about this one oh well I
mean I wouldn't even here we go dude you
give me you guys give me no credit no no
no that's that is true I was gonna say
that's not true you pick good videos no
you do pick good videos but you have
probably have someone doing that for you
you farm that one out uh no that was a
very great very great choice of video
Chris very good interesting submission
and frankly I ca I can't
believe it but I didn't even consider
that I I actually I kind of was thinking
that that's why I said what I said but
she put it into words way better than I
did which is crazy because I'm in order
it's like a it's like a Freudian thing
yes well no because she might not even
have known but don't Yeah well yeah even
if it wasn't intentionally she could
have been doing it to sabotage but my
whole thing is don't [__] sneeze dude
just don't sneeze or
haven't you ever sneezed when you didn't
want to sneeze though yeah but really
quietly
you threw up you know we're like in the
other room oh here it comes who's it's
not like you don't know it's coming but
but here let's let's maybe you're never
just like oh yeah if we're gonna if
we're gonna speculate though what if he
also didn't even tell the friend because
of whatever it could be a number of
reasons right you know he was like yo
don't don't say [__] be quiet don't
don't you know I mean you would think
he's just testing or he's on the phone
yeah yeah honey with Hairspray
pepper yeah honey a feather
uh
uh I don't know man that was a good
video it was a great video I thought
about it and I just thought I was just
you know I was just like I'm 11. I love
and laugh I love and love what a great
recap dude yeah she did good she should
come on the show should she want to be
the 30th of the show you should be a
[__] footballer now she should sit
right here a football announcer with
that there he goes Lauren long down down
the road down the [__] 10-yard line
any touchdown there we go you know what
that was amazing you just kind of ran
and got a touchdown you know me I'm just
loving life
oh dude we should ask these people first
I've been doing that for years and I'm
convinced there is a song that that does
that and people that are listening now
please know what the song is what we're
doing okay all it is in my mind yeah is
love and life I love and laugh hello
okay it is that a song
I mean how many years is this though
this is like that will be an 80s song or
a 90s song there's no [__] way to
think of what
okay so we had cable and because we're
two boys and we were like eight and
eleven when we were kids we had people
in our rooms
not a good idea you know I mean yeah
this is a lifelong luxury story but okay
it is but I gotta say yeah
uh we were watching.com we watched like
a soft porn yeah yeah and we were let me
tell you we were 11 live yeah and at the
end of the movie uh we watched until the
credits you know because we're eight and
eleven and the song was that the the
hook on it was I got a woody all right
and we thought it was the funnest thing
ever and then because YouTube is so
great we found this song years later yep
and let me tell you something
it's the worst song of all time oh it's
the worst just look up it's I got a
woody so we'll play it on we'll play it
on Lifeline luxury because we can yeah
and imagine us laughing at it we died
laughing I got a woody all right cool
I got a woody yeah yeah no I got a woody
oh yeah [__] man how unsexy is the term
Woody dude it's the worst oh yeah baby
oh baby hey baby uh put your hand on my
woody
I mean what's what's the uh equal for
box I want to suck my woody oh yeah I
feel so good on my woody what about
weenie dude that's the least sexy thing
Woody's a little bit better than weenie
oh baby oh God I feel so good on my
weenie don't do the fake kiss sound dude
so disgusting hey stop ew that's kissing
I know what it is I've done it I've done
it okay oh man Ah that's my weenie ah I
feel so good on my weenie I mean also
though like okay what word would that
would those words be acceptable you know
ah man I feel so good on my weenie the
biggest person just having sex with an
actual whale
Amazon woman nine feet tall that'd be
cool it's like where Wonder Woman lives
well all right um nerd you know it's
like we're Wonder Woman lives
he's done so much dude this guy's on so
much right now and also always go back
ah dude so much coke in one second
yo what up Lifeline wow uh big fan of
Christmas so yeah DC oh nice Matt
[__] Trail as [__]
um my question is what do you say to
people that like call out when you're
rocking like a new article of clothing
or like a piece of jewelry
I just got this gold chain yeah
I need something to say to people that
call it out yeah thanks yeah I I I I
understand let me just [__] put on
what I want and don't say [__] about it
I know I know you do so what say
something about like my change or
something oh dude it's cool you got two
chains on oh you noticed yeah oh you
noticed yeah ah oh my God the worst guy
you know you get real like up close in
them and up close to their face did you
just notice because I have them on
that's crazy yeah oh oh my God yeah um
yeah it's annoying dude it's annoying
it's like I mean I even feel that way
about haircuts are you gonna just get a
haircut yeah that is annoying you know I
did you notice on my hair I'll go first
you want to talk about my haircut what
the [__] is this I'll go further you
know what I don't like when people are
like I saw you posted on Instagram I I
feel so like do you know what leave that
for the internet just comment don't be
talking about what I posted on Instagram
but what if they have something to say
about it actually text it to me wow I
mean so many rules okay so if they have
something if that's like a real to say
about a post they need to text it to you
no if they actually have something real
to say but if they're like
dude
that [__] story you did with the
[__] other guy in it oh man it makes
me feel weird just leaving for the leave
it for the leave it for the Instagram
that's weird yeah am I you agree I'm
surprised you agree all right you're not
surprised but I do agree yeah
oh I'm not nope
dude
what's up man
you Feast your eyes on that
I'm looking
what do you want what do you think about
that do it again
I'm gonna add it up can I just pull it
up
pretty surprising that that's a snake
you got a [__] snake on your arm yeah
right there what I mean I know where it
is but why what do you mean what is it
you can see it's a snake but it like
from this angle it looks like it might
be like a ball sack nope
no okay but why is it if your balls look
like that you're in trouble huh why a
snake
um
because they're in the grass of the Log
Cabin we gotta watch out all right I
forgot you have the whole like story
going on
also just learned lore yesterday it's
the second it's the second time you use
the word in 24 hours
I'm Kevin lore I believe you that's cool
the snake is out of proportion to the
house though it's as big as the house
yeah it's a symbol dude okay but it's
like a little weenie [__] dick in the
grass is it like is it like perspective
like it's closer or it's just separate
entirely no it's just it's just a
[__] mural you know how murals go
yeah but it's not a mural though it is a
mural on my [__] bicep you know it's
a tattoo
yeah but it's a mural of art on my
[__] bicep and triceps no no no no no
no you don't say like did you see the
painting I have on my arm which is a
tattoo that's not what you do you could
say that and I would understand what you
mean what it meant but it's a mural
because of this is my art my my my my
body's my diary and this is my journal
okay okay man
anyway
that snake's just on a branch just
living life you know what I mean yeah
dude I mean I you came in the right
place because I definitely know what you
mean yeah all right cool so next one
who's next
Parkinson's disease Parkinson's disease
uh he's also on the decline since he and
my mum is his uh full-time carer she's
also a grandmother
um sometimes I'll get a call from work
he's fallen over I'm gonna go pick him
up take him to hospital [__] like that
nurses have said we need to uh get help
she's eligible to have a nurse come in
Daily to do the rounds like mum's load
but she loves her peace and quiet right
woman of Solitude
how do we nudge her to allow the help he
needs talk to my siblings about an
intervention probably won't go well
she'll get defensive she has mental
health issues herself
um so how do we do it lovingly without
pushing her over the edge
what do you think you know
uh mum's peace and quiet Dad's health I
I know the answer yeah but uh I just
need a little bit of help in in what do
you mean
uh he knows what they should do they
should have someone come and help us
I think
like a lot of things
you have to when you deliver the news
you say it like it's a [__] present
that you're getting her
you say it like it's it's a gift for her
to enjoy you get to take some time off a
little less stress just in and out for a
few hours every day whatever and you get
to just kick back and actually have your
own peace and quiet dude spin it like
that you have to have your own peace and
quiet manipulative
why are you saying that because you know
you know that she doesn't want to but
you're manipulating the situation no I
think that you did I got you something
I'm not gonna say I think
I think that he believes he is doing his
mom a favor I think that he just also
believes that she's not gonna understand
it until it's there in place happening
right she he's not like [__] over his
mom no I know she needs help and she's
gonna deny it out of Pride and like
habit dude I got your meet and greet 25
fingers
uh
um did you make what is Johnny Five I
don't know you just can't just make that
up I guess I did I don't know there's a
real thing I have no it's not definitely
not you know it could be something
already uh since I'm creative so uh but
yeah dude you know she's gonna get
defensive you got to take the big swing
and make it sound like
it is what it is which is like a gift
for yeah Mom do you want to be love and
live I got you something exactly yeah
that's not a bad that's not a bad advice
is you know
um otherwise you're just gonna get the
pushback that you know true like you
want your piece of quiet you get peace
and quiet look I get it dude times are
changing and it's gonna be tough and
change is always weird but it's also
inevitable so you know you need help he
needs help let's just do this and we got
you this and and you know I set it all
up for you you don't have to do anything
if you don't like him or her when they
come like we'll get a new one but like
this is good dad needs it yep and like
it's gonna make your life a lot easier
and you you deserve it get her internet
you know make it about her make it about
her gaming you deserve this mom here
play among us see if you like it okay
yeah I guess
I could also get a replacement too if
you want yeah I mean I think that's good
I think that's uh
that's good advice cool
sorry to hear about that yeah that sucks
man I'm sorry sucks I'm really sorry
dude
hey Chris and Matt so uh so I just was
driving home from work and I called up
my my best friend
um I was just planning out something
that was going to happen in a couple of
weeks and we were just like talking and
I was telling him something funny and
then all of a sudden he's [__] silent
right and then you just hear like a
seven second delayed little tiny giggle
oh my God this [__] is using his phone
while he's talking to me so how I called
him out I said I I just said like oh
dude you're on your [__] phone and
he's just like yeah sorry like I'm just
doing all this and he told me what he's
doing on his phone like all right I'm
gonna let you go but what's a better way
when you know somebody's on their
goddamn phone while they're talking to
you on the phone
um to hit him with something like
[__] make him feel like [__] about it
or
or just uh you know call him out better
because you know it's just kind of like
really dude if I'm talking to you face
to face and then all of a sudden I'm
just like
yeah yeah that's funny yeah [__] you
dude so Texas
um any advice
text someone you're talking on the phone
yeah I know you're doing DM on Instagram
I know you're doing text him and say
[__] you I know what you're doing yeah
that's the move dude uh couldn't uh that
guy I liked his whole thing his demeanor
and everything he seemed cool say why
I don't know man it was just seemed like
easy going even though he's calling in
with like a gripe he seemed like he was
just chill like he wasn't really that
mad about it and he laughed during the
thing like he just thought he was just
very comfortable and uh
he doesn't seem threatening he seems
like a nice guy
I like that guy my next question is why
don't you marry him
I mean he set me up you know something
not even really that way no if you like
him that much you know I don't marry
people you like have him co-host this
podcast with you okay it's deeper you
don't marry people you like if they love
them okay well it sounds like you might
love that guy I don't think I love him
uh I mean knows demo you love him you
know so I don't
I don't I don't know
I don't know I don't know about texting
is that enough I don't know man I I just
think that honestly he wants to drag his
friend for be making him feel like why
are you even talking on the phone that's
what I was actually gonna say so what
are you guys talking about I know the
solution of this get off the phone what
are you talking about serious [__]
you know in movies when they're like
well if it was serious he wouldn't be
doing the thing he was doing playing
games right how about this you be more
interesting yeah how about that be be
more memorable like we say hey dude
maybe your friend's playing games on his
phone while you're talking to him
because you're a [__] as exciting as
a mausoleum yep maybe I maybe I didn't
was wrong in thinking that you were cool
and I like you maybe you're actually not
as interesting as lore wow dude you know
fitting the word Lauren now um not even
in situations where it's where it works
no but I just think that uh yeah I think
that who cares really I don't even think
you care I think that uh also what are
you talking about on the phone right
that's kind of weird man also no I think
what you should do all things considered
when you realize they're doing something
else say just stop what you're saying
even in the middle of a sentence and
just say [__] you and hang up oh wow
that's really aggressive but it's just
as rude it is rude as hell dude like
just get off the phone with the person
it is rude in the favor of not wasting
their breath like
it's not rude to get off also why did
the guy admit that he was doing
something else because you know it's
like if they're good friends like uh
he's just [__] and it's like you're
even listening he's like nah nah but
here's me if I'm in that conversation
I'm looking at my phone and I was like
you look at another phone I'm like yeah
yeah yeah dude you're being [__] like
say other [__] yeah you you would say
that I would I would dude it was so
boring what these people were talking
about a few nights ago and I couldn't
even believe it I mean that is so vague
what are you learning English Where Were
You Who were they checked out I didn't
talk with them and then afterwards I was
like guys you know I don't know man and
then we talked about something else and
they got mad at me you were with these
people yeah okay do I mean just do
better telling that story because all
you did was get to the middle end middle
slash end and then end it and no one no
one had any contacts for what you were
saying do you know what I mean I thought
I I started late in the story which is
what you're supposed to do with a good
story you're supposed to start as late
as possible into the story getting a lot
of text did you know that that uh I
actually did know that yeah it's like a
movie maker thing yeah and I know that
too so I was just checking my fantasy
baseball stuff I think I'm gonna write a
horror movie
nice what's it called uh artifice girl
artifice girls lore 30 is one called
Lore horror really yeah there's a I
don't know there was a podcast famous
podcast called Laura oh they turned it
into something but that was not a but no
I can't remember a while ago that guy we
got an argument on Twitter me and that
guy the creator of lore oh really yeah
yeah the pocket I can't remember bro I
cannot remember wow I was like you're a
[__] [__] dude oh wow Jesus he was I
mean but then also like back then I was
a [__] fiery like a like a real like
reactionary dude okay well man I'm a
little bit more chill now things change
things do change okay what's up what do
we got we didn't came one more or
something [__]
so check it out I have like a slight
gambling problem oh
dude literally not wearing a shirt
because he it yeah yeah and is in
because that's furthest away closet yep
away from so his wife doesn't yeah yeah
because he already lost the house like a
slight gambling problem go go back go
back go back I mean there is no such
thing by the way as a slight game no not
really no
hey what up Chris and Matt let's check
it out I have like a slight gambling
problem
um gambling I probably made
something between 40 and 60 000 in the
last two years online gambling
and the swings are up and down obviously
you know but losers obviously pays the
bills I mean that's a lot of money
um up more than I'm down and I probably
need to stop because when the swings are
low it affects everything yeah so that's
a drunk uh what do you guys think should
I just cut it out and just take my job
is what it is and you know make like 100
Grand a year yeah I mean is he okay with
that or should I continue to push and I
hope that it you know the swings go up
let me know thanks ah yes get out of
that bro that sounds like a [__]
problem waiting to happen so I mean it
is a problem when
you're up okay when you're gambling and
you're you go way up which this guy
obviously did and then you go way down
but you're still technically up it's two
things that you realize one is that
you know you're playing a losing game
and you know you need to stop but at no
time is the impulse to bet more and get
that high back stronger than after you
lose winnings not you lose your money
but when winnings go away the urge to
get that went back to reattane that high
is so strong stronger than at any other
time and for all of those reasons you
should absolutely do everything you can
100 to stop now yeah because you're
gonna end up yeah and it's gonna it's
harder to stop the longer you do it I
feel like addiction it you know it's
like
I I would honestly
I would try to look I would try to have
you tried to stop before that's the
thing that I think that you should you
should think about have you tried to
stop before because if you have tried to
stop before and you didn't then that's
straight up addiction you know if like
you know the lows are so bad and you
can't stop even though you want to like
that's the definition of addiction so
you gotta try and somehow get some help
actually
um because gambling addiction is [__]
rude old dude uh you'll ruin your life I
mean I know some people here who are
gamblers and it's just they've ruined
ruined their lives so
um yeah uh uh I would say stop honestly
my heart felt responses stop because
also dude
I understand everybody's struggling and
it's hard to make money but if you're
making a hundred thousand dollars a year
that's a fine living like I mean
especially west side of L.A yeah exactly
in L.A it's impossible but like you know
wherever you live like that's a fine
living dude it's not like you're making
000 a year to where you're like I gotta
do something yeah that's the thing like
you're gonna [__] your life up dude
the whole reason why you're making this
video is because you know that there
might be a problem so if there might be
a problem then there is a problem just
it's like when you think somebody might
be gay and you're and you're like really
like oh no no actually if I'm even
thinking that he's definitely smoked
some poles you know what I'm saying so I
mean not a necessary analogy though you
know what I mean yeah it is though you
know because it's actually clearer with
the gambling it is because of the money
thing but honestly if
you sucking polls was money you'd you
know you maybe think differently about
it you'd be like oh is he gay oh wait
the fact that I'm thinking that he's
definitely smoke some poles right so
smoke some poor yeah I do think I do
think that you should stop I think you
should stop
especially since you kind of are [__]
making you have a job dude you also lost
your shirt literally I mean that is an
expression yeah
symbolically it's very funny that you
called in with you yeah dude exactly you
lost your shirt literally and you're
gonna lose your shirt financially if you
keep betting yeah I'm telling you I get
it why you want to keep going more than
you did even when you first started
really way up this is this is not
complicated it's not confusing you're a
very people don't like to hear this all
the time but what you're experiencing is
actually
extremely typical
at this juncture you start to realize I
gotta stop or else it's gonna get really
really bad that's why you're asking and
it's all all things are pointing to you
gotta stop right now
the big thing for me is if you tried to
stop before and you couldn't then you
guys what if he hasn't tried to stop
before it wouldn't lessen the amount he
needs he needs to stop still I know that
but I'm just saying that's a huge
wake-up call into where you know the
cycle has started and you're [__] yeah
but yeah it's easier to nip it in the
bud per se which sounds like it's
already too late for that but yeah I
don't know you haven't lost your [__]
nothing will feel worse than when you
lose money that you needed you haven't
done that yet save yourself the trouble
um
interesting it's it's the worst feeling
is that it
you you like to gamble or what oh yeah
would you have a gambling problem no I
don't do it anymore oh you used to yeah
but not not anymore yeah um no not
anymore no I used to do it like you
should do it with what like baseball
yeah like baseball betting yeah but
they're not legal right like it's all
legal [__] I would do legal yeah so what
would you mean not like that oh yeah
that's a lot of money
I mean that is like 50 60 Grand yeah he
lost or was like was betting at one time
no I don't have a [__]
a betting to me gambling is just not
something that I have any desire to do
I don't know why it's just I mean it's
almost never about money for people
people for women it's about money
usually do pretty well because it's
they're colder about it and they're like
well I'm not gonna do that that's not
gonna make me money
emotional gamblers are the people who
get ruined yeah because it doesn't
matter yeah it's the what is the biggest
head [__] for gambling addicts is that
it's not the high of a win right it's
the high of a low that you're right
right that's that's the most losing game
you can imagine it's the chaos yeah yeah
it's the possibility of the low you feel
more comfortable in chaos so much is on
the line and you're just like it's just
the most literally Stakes are higher
than anything could possibly be uh so
people get a high from that and it's the
worst [__] thing to get a high from
um
[Music]
okay well I hope you get some help uh
Happy Father's Day
and uh go to Lifeline luxury patreon.com
lifelong luxury we get at least what do
we have three four episodes out now
um
watch them we've been having episodes
come out every week so far we've said at
least two a month uh but we've been
doing more than that we have we have we
have
no no this has been three right
yeah but there are more than two
episodes
fourth episode
he's right
yeah this will be the fourth
right okay so this is the third all
right all right cool so we're doing more
than two this month so there you go
you're gonna have three if you sign but
there will be four to patreon.com yes
there will be uh go to watch
lifetime.com if you have a thing if you
have a video you want to send to us and
get the lifeline merch uh
lifelinemerch.com and tickets dude I'm
gonna be in Colorado uh coming up
chrisley.com Colorado Vegas and
Nashville and Little Rock mattelier.com
if you want a one-on-one private session
don't need to blow up your face and your
problems on the show you can have a
session with me private don't tell
nobody give you good advice everybody's
happy uh if you're making a point with
me I love you forever if you don't I
hate you forever wow and yeah see you
next week or if you are a patron who
are all my best friends for the rest of
Eternity then you we will see you at
Lifeline luxury as well wow
[Music]